- Get ready for
fire memes.
New merch alert with crazy
cool Chest Compressions design.
It's limited, two weeks, buy it.
Huge thank you to ShipStation
for sponsoring this video.
Normal people, Instagram models.
Yo. Facts on facts on facts on facts.
That's not healthy.
The curves are there in
your spine for a reason.
When you over-accentuate them,
you actually create a problem.
Iron deficiency. (laughing) Oh my God.
I wouldn't say that's
an iron deficiency, man.
I would say this is
like cachectic Iron Man.
But I get the joke.
Made it medical for no reason.
Doctors always ruining jokes.
High five, 50% less
bacteria than a handshake.
Fist bump, 78% less
Sweep the leg, 100% less
bacteria than a handshake.
You think I'm gonna agree with this?
No, I'm not.
What is my man touching there?
The floor. Do you know
how gross the floor is?
Disgusting.
Have you ever been to a hospital?
The fluids, the bacteria,
the viruses, the fungi, the protozoa.
Do you even know what a protozoa is?
Feeling great since my kidney transplant.
My kidney transplant?
The kid's knee transplant.
I never get the ones with the knee.
This knee.
Da sa ni.
This knee. Oh that's a knee!
When it's your first day at
the pediatric department.
(laughs)
No lie, I may have done that.
My attending, who was teaching
me that day, was like,
"Okay, we're going to start slow.
And I'm going to teach
you the burrito roll".
Where they actually teach
you how to burrito roll
the baby into the blanket in order
so the baby feels
swaddled and comfortable.
That was a fun trick to learn.
Cause then I went into all
the rooms in the morning.
I was teaching the parents
as if I really knew
what I was doing.
Wow. The COVIDs out here are getting huge.
Oh my God. When I was a kid,
I would throw these at my
friends all the time and get them
to stick to their hoodies.
And I would get in trouble
because the teacher's be like
"Oh my God, you might hit an eye."
And they were right, but I was a bad kid.
I like how when a doctor pulls
some medicine into a syringe,
they squirt a little in the
air for their fallen homies.
(laughs)
It's like tsch-tsch.
Now what we're doing
is we're trying to get
the air bubbles out.
If you inject too much air
into someone's bloodstream,
you could actually get an
air embolism. Huge problem.
It can be lethal,
but still we'd like to get it
out and make sure that we're
flush.
Mito corn,
mito corn jury og.
This is really great because
mitochondria kind of does look
like a corn dog. It also
looks like a regular,
just like hotdog.
Skeleton parts identified.
But if you were any bone in
the human body, comment down
below. I asked this on
Twitter, I got weird responses.
Medical alphabet.
This is what they teach us
in med school, by the way.
Confuse the lawyers
so they can't go after you.
Because if they say that
you didn't write something,
you could just point to
a scribble and be like,
what do you think this is?
Doctor: I have your diagnosis.
Me: Make it quick. I don't have much time.
Doctor: Who told you that?
That's sad.
How coffee works. Coffee, magic, energy.
Oh, my God.
Am I going to really have to
go into the nerdy explanation
of why coffee works?
I'm not going to do that.
I'm just going to laugh at this meme.
Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh.
What a terrible gift.
John Cena surprises seven
year old boy with cancer on
his birthday.
What? Oh.
The importance of gram, gram, grammar.
I forgot what the importance
of grandpa commas being.
Get your flu shot now
available in pumpkin spice.
If we want vaccine
acceptance to go sky high,
you throw that in a Gucci
vial, you know influencers
are coming up. And then
when that gets old,
you do the Gucci Supreme collab.
Yo, that shit's going to be hot.
Back to the memes in just a second
but first I want to talk to you about
ShipStation.
Look, if you ever had
to ship anything before,
I don't need to tell you
how frustrating it can be,
but thanks to ShipStation,
shipping will become the easiest part of
your online business.
It's order management and
shipping software is designed to
make your life hassle-free,
which will really come in handy
this holiday season.
From the dashboard,
you can easily import orders
from Amazon, eBay, Etsy,
even your own website and
automate just about every shipping
task.
They work with international
and local shipping companies
around the world like FedEx and UPS,
and you even get access to
discounted rates that are usually
reserved for Fortune500 companies.
90% of companies that use
ShipStation for a year
keep using it for as long as
they're in business and with
more people shopping
online this holiday season
you'll want help making
your orders stress free.
Just go to ShipStation.com/DoctorMike,
remember Doctor is spelled out,
to get a 60 day free trial now.
All right, let's get back to the memes.
It looks like she needs
a crown. I know, right?
Yes, Queen. Slay.
(laughs)
That's funny. All my dentists
out there, what's up?
You want a box for those, sir?
Nah, I hate violence.
Is it cool if I just pay with my card?
Yo, I'll box for those.
As some of you may know,
I've been boxing lately.
I've been getting some
challengers coming my way,
but I want more. So if you want to box me,
I'm like 195 pounds, six foot three.
You want to do it?
HMU.
Who says HMU?
Boomer.
- You're in rare form.
I'm in,
I'm in boomer form.
Doctor: Your dad's not with us anymore.
Me: Damn.
Doctor: He's at a different hospital.
Me: Oh, okay.
Doctor: Dead, though.
No, that's not what we do.
And this guy does not look like
a real doctor because he has
his shirt buttoned all the way
up and he doesn't have a tie.
I'm not sure what's going on there.
Doctor: You need surgery in this section.
It's probably best to
remove the whole spine.
Woman: Why?
Doctor: It's just holding you back.
No, you, you, you kind of need the spine.
It's supportive.
Great hike.
You lost 159 pounds.
Oh what? Oh, the bear.
Oh my God. Bear, would you ever do that?
Bear's down here. He wouldn't do that.
- To Mike's dismay, it
turned out that Bear was
in fact not there.
- Would you like a drink?
What are my options?
Yes.
This, like, sparked a memory.
When we were first coming to America,
none of us spoke English.
They were asking me if I'd
like a drink and I didn't know
what the questions meant.
And I was like, maybe?
The lady was so confused.
So my sister was like,
he wants a Coke. As a
six-year-old. I wasn't that wise.
What inspired you to go
into family medicine?
Oh, I'm excited to read the bottom.
Hello, I hate money, and I love burnout.
Excuse me, family medicine doctors
can still make a great
living. And we burn out.
We do burn out.
This machine turns stress
into visible light.
I am the sun.
Not all stress is bad stress.
Overcoming short-term stress
is positive because we learned
from it and prepared for the real world,
which carries stress inherently within.
What we don't like is chronic
stress that serves no benefit.
And we learn to live with
the stresses that we cannot
control. Buddhist mentality.
I don't know why I did this.
I just wanted peace, sanctuary.
I'm afraid there was a mix-up.
I was supposed to amputate your left leg.
(crickets)
Why is the doctor saying that?
The doctor amputated their own left leg.
Honestly, at this point,
how burnt out we are?
Not surprising.
I also like don't know
why there are snakes
coming out of that patient monitor.
When your chest starts hurting and you hit
the spot where it's hurting and it stops.
Health. Health.
Health. Heelth. Hoo. Whoa.
Me working on notes.
I can't keep doing this forever. Honestly.
I relate to that like crazy.
It's been 20 seconds. Call it.
For some reason, when
I started doing notes,
I do one note, enjoying
the dopamine rush so much
that I pick up my phone
and I'm like, forget these.
When you look better in scrubs
than you do in the clubs.
Facts.
Professional rappers.
The guy who says the side
effects of a medicine in an ad.
You ever hear the side
effects, not an ad on TV,
but an ad on the radio.
It's literally like the substantial
side effects of the lung
cancer containing carcinogens
that are affecting your
brainwaves are going
to have one time that.
Trying to be an adult and
read a scientific paper
and your wife does this.
Harry Potter and.
That's funny though.
Chest compressions. Chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compression.
What do you think about my shirt?
You want it? You can get it.
It's right there.
48 hour protection.
My deodorant.
The doctor's saying I have
24 hours left to live. Well,
the deodorant is really going
to give you the bang for the
buck.
The deodorant's going to give
you a good bang for the buck.
I don't know what trying to say here.
I'm gonna have some water.
I have three plants that are
flourishing and one that's
dying.
I don't know what I did wrong
to the one that's dying.
That's so good whoever created that.
That was an old fake plant
that used to be my videos
in my previous apartment.
And that plant is forever
immortalized. Oh yeah.
That's the plant.
Well, that's not the plant.
That's a replica of the
plant made by the Patreon
community. If you want to join,
you get access to our
Discord, monthly live streams,
all that good stuff. Links down below.
Silica gel: do not eat.
Oh my God, those silica packets.
I have some kind of fear
that I'm going to drop it and
Bear's going to munch on it.
Congratulations.
You've escaped the simulation. Okay.
We're going to have a serious
conversation. Don't do this.
Don't eat the silica gel packets.
If you want to continue
being happy and healthy,
you shouldn't eat them.
Perfect Tinder profile doesn't exist.
I'm dying to meet you. When can ICU?
This guy's DMs are probably
exploding right now.
Swipe right.
You'll die by 2055.
I still have a lot of
time to go to school,
marry and have a job.
Oh, you're saying it in
military time. Oh my God.
It's so evil. And the doctors are always.
Medical show accuracy. Doctor Mike.
No lie, I'm coming for you.
I don't care if you're a big
show, small show, I'm coming.
Removing the scab on your wound,
your blood platelets that
have been working for days.
Why peel the scab? People do that a lot.
And they think drying out
the wound is better. Nope.
Keeping it covered and moist is better.
What part of the body always loses?
The colon.
Defeat.
They always get me. Do
you want to see defeat?
Should I make an OnlyFans?
Prevent carpal tunnel.
No, slouch shoulders, bent wrists.
Yes, running into woods,
never to be seen again.
Honestly, quite accurate.
You want to avoid pressure on
the flexor retinaculum here,
which is the fibrous band
that sits at the edge of your
wrist that keeps the median
nerve protected and tight.
I made this into an educational thing,
they're talking about bears or something.
Sorry.
Need books? No worries. Donate plasma.
Me: I cannot afford tuition.
United States: Then pay with your blood.
We had someone on our YouTube channel,
not too long ago, on a plasma video
say that day did this a lot
through college in order to make
some extra money on the side.
United States is one of a
few countries that allows
companies to pay for your plasma.
But it's all going to a good
purpose so I don't mind that.
Who did it better?
No lie. I think mine's better.
Mine's real.
Pikachu? Fake.
This guy? Acting.
Me? Legit.
Above knee.
Okay. I get it. I get
you're trying to get me with
the knee things.
Oh, that's a knee!
If that's a tattoo that
someone got though,
you're putting your body
on the line for humor.
I got ants.
Yeah, but my ants were taller than yours.
Yeah, well I got a tube of glue.
And I have an entire tin of it.
I got bread. Oh, you win.
I can't handle that with my
glue tin and taller ants.
I think I need to be
either drunk to read this.
Can't handle that with
my gluten intolerance.
Stop laughing, Sam. This is...
Are the ants on something?
Do the items have a connection?
Ice and kit?
Let me know when you need a lifeline.
I can't handle that with my
glue tin and taller ants.
I can't, I give up. What is it?
- Okay, who can't eat bread?
- A celiac.
- Because celiac people are...?
- Because they have inflammation
or, what's the question?
- We're so close. Bread contains...
- Wheat.
- You can't eat bread because
it contains... gluten.
- Okay. Yeah. Ah, you win.
I can't handle that with
my gluten and taller ants.
Intolerance.
Wow. Who came up with that?
There is no normal person
that's thinking about ants,
glue and bread.
Reacting to viral surgery videos here,
including Michael Reeves
surgical robot. Crazy.
Click here to check that out and huge
thank you to ShipStation
for sponsoring this video.
As always, stay happy and stay healthy.